[Music]
when you're sitting outdoors and it
starts getting chilly
you can shiver put on more layers of
clothing or press a button to let the
furniture you're sitting on warm you up
designed for use in the outdoors and in
colder indoor spaces heated furniture is
a hot new trend this heated lounge is
hip and practical discreet drain holes
prevent rain water from puddling and the
easy to reach heat control knob is
located underneath the seat benches
multi SI lounges and single chairs can
all be made into heated furniture the
first step is to code a fiberglass mold
with a release agent once a rubber
insert is glued into the drain hole a
technician mixes the ingredients for the
casting material together ingredients
included pigment containing metal oxides
which prevent color fading a concrete
mix containing a blend of fibers for
extra strength and resistance and water
containing proprietary additives the
ingredients are mixed together for about
three minutes until the concrete is the
consistency of cake batter a thin layer
is sprayed onto the fiberglass mold and
any raised areas are flattened to remove
air bubbles
the chairs color will never rub off or
peel because the pigment is mixed right
into the concrete next technicians add
the heating element a cable that is
wrapped around the piece of furniture
the cable is tacked in place with a
separate mix of concrete that has a
higher fiber content the entire heating
element is embedded in a full coat of
the high fiber concrete then a finishing
coat of the first mix is applied and the
structure is left to cure at room
temperature for 24 hours now cured this
white chair is ready to be extracted a
technician pumps compressed air through
the drain hole insert due to the release
agent application the cast chair easily
pops off the mold the rough edges are
smooth with a diamond file then the
drain hole plug is removed
at another station a technician coats
the entire surface of another chair with
a sealant that blocks moisture moisture
penetration weakens concrete and draws
out the natural salt which leaves white
stains meanwhile a welder constructs the
chairs frame with parts made out of
stainless steel tubes and plates the
chair has three legs plus cross members
that act as conduits for electrical
wires the cross members connect to a
stainless steel box which will house the
temperature control unit
a technician fills a channel with
adhesive along the perimeter he places
the frame into the channel the adhesive
will take a day to cure
next the electrical wiring is assembled
the technician fishes to electrical
wires through the frame one wire
connects the power cord plug to the
temperature control unit the other runs
from the temperature control unit to the
temperature control switch he glues the
switch into a hole in the right front
leg all the wires are embedded in rubber
making them waterproof the temperature
control unit is installed in the box at
the center of the frame then a
temperature sensor is installed
underneath the seat the technician
hammers plastic and stainless steel feet
into the bottom of the legs this
prevents the legs from scratching the
floor and levels the furniture on an
uneven surface lastly a bronze drain is
inserted into the drain hole a quality
controlled heat test measures the
surface temperature with an infrared
thermometer
if all is operating correctly the sensor
under the C tells the thermostat in the
temperature control unit when to turn
the heat on or off